[Music]
this week tesla unveiled plans to build
a personal assistant humanoid robot
called what else the tesla bot
elon musk says the robot is designed to
do boring repetitive even dangerous work
he joked the tesla bots will also be
able to be slow enough that they can be
outrun
the company's aiming to have a prototype
ready right i mean if it wants to come
after you
some people might be afraid you know
this development comes as questions are
being raised about the safety of the
autopilot feature in tesla vehicles the
nation's top auto safety regulator is
investigating nearly a dozen accidents
where a tesla slammed into a parked
emergency vehicle two senators are
calling on the federal trade commission
to launch a separate investigation
congressional correspondent chris van
cleeve has more
this tesla slammed into a california
highway patrol suv stopped on a closed
freeway as officers investigated a fatal
crash last month the driver allegedly
told police she'd engaged autopilot and
wasn't paying attention there was
officers inside that vehicle it could
have been a lot worse if somebody's
outside next to the car they can easily
kill an officer it's at least the 11th
time since 2018 where a tesla using
advanced driver assistance technology
hit a stopped emergency vehicle federal
regulators are now investigating those
crashes that resulted in reports of 17
injuries and one death among them this
2018 collision where a tesla slammed
into the back of a fire truck the
national transportation safety board
blamed driver error and autopilot's
design i do believe there's a problem
there cbs news transportation safety
analyst rob sumwalt was the ntsb
chairman during that investigation
what's the concern with calling
something autopilot concern with calling
it an autopilot is that people get over
confident this is not an autopilot at
all it needs to be constantly monitored
just like an autopilot on an airplane
now senators ed markey and richard
blumenthal are demanding the federal
trade commission launch its own
investigation into potentially deceptive
and unfair practices in tesla's
advertising and marketing tesla has been
overstating
vastly
and falsely overstating the capabilities
of its autopilot
system the consequences
can be deadly autopilot can maintain the
car's speed and lane position but tesla
says the driver must stay in control and
pay proper attention the company did not
respond to our request for comment but
has stood by its technology arguing it
reduces accidents while the automaker
continues to update the system it is not
foolproof during this 2018 drive in a
tesla model 3 autopilot nearly steered
me into another vehicle as two lanes
merged together it
nearly drove us into the subaru not
quite a perfect system so at that point
the car was not aware that there was
another car that was about to steer into
us the probe could affect an estimated
765 000 teslas currently on the road for
cbs this morning saturday chris van
cleave washington
the prospect of
being able to chill or nap or eat some
food and not having to drive yourself is
obviously intriguing but a lot still
needs to get worked out right as someone
who's been in an accident because i fell
asleep
you know had dozed off it is
crucial that you have a backup i think
for you know the kinks need to be worked
out yeah a lot of folks might think
autopilot means you can do that and just
yeah you cannot sit there and be alert
but that's clearly not the case yeah and
i'm alive in here to tell the story well
they're happy for it me too oh thank you